xena and her boyfriend lay are psychotic
maniacs in love they are currently in a
courtroom planning something big a world
famous gangster named [ __ ] has been
caught and is being convicted for
murders assaults robbery and many
unforgivable crimes being his lawyer
xena takes a stand against the judge's
decision suddenly her boyfriend lay gets
up from the audience and starts firing
at everyone he is joined by his gang
members who are here to rescue [ __ ]
after killing everyone present in the
courtroom xena and lai start making out
[ __ ] orders them to let him out of the
handcuffs first but they only laugh at
him suddenly [ __ ] notices an explosive
in their hands which blows up and kills
him while the couple is miraculously
left unharmed the scene cuts to a
flashback when xena was first caught by
[ __ ] he assaulted her in front of lay
who couldn't raise his voice because he
was scared of kuhn's power he silently
tried to commit the unthinkable but the
bullets in the revolver ran short at
that moment he vowed to make kun pay he
also picked up zena telling her that
their lives belong to each other back in
the present the couple's dream to kill
kun is finally accomplished outside a
swat team is waiting for the hearing to
end their only job is to escort kun out
until captain goo hears a gunshot
without waiting for official orders he
makes his way inside with his team they
get into an intense shootout with lay's
man xena pretends to be a damsel in
distress and then stabs goo in the back
but he manages to save himself and catch
both xena and her boyfriend ultimately
lay sets off another explosive that
kills him and blinds goo forever xena on
the other hand cries while holding her
boyfriend's body while being arrested
she vows to avenge his death by killing
everyone goo loves in the following
scene goo is told that he will never be
able to see again his only family is his
daughter and his brother-like friend yan
they help him to the best of their
abilities but the trauma caused by the
incident haunts goo every night the
public blames him for all the deaths
because he is the only swat personnel
who came out alive from the court
because of public pressure he also loses
his job for the first week goo goes
crazy and starts breaking things in the
house his daughter sia keeps him sane
most of the time but in her absence he
can hardly think or work eventually her
playing the violin becomes his only way
to relax as days pass goo starts to heal
he also begins working on his hearing
and other senses now that he can no
longer see one day he surprises sia by
catching a ball thrown toward him goo is
becoming daredevil to test his skills
she throws several balls at him and
finds out that he has mastered the art
of seeing without eyes in only a few
months jan is amazed by his friend when
goo can tell exactly where he is
standing just by sensing his presence
six months after the incident sia and
goo decide to go to manila for a
symphony competition in the meantime
xena is still in prison counting the
days until she can see goo again the
gangster koon had a son named kang who
desperately wants to kill zena to do so
he sends a petition to move her to a
different prison in manula but xena
knows about his intentions so she
refuses to sign the consent papers sia
and goo land in manula and go directly
to the theater for the competition sia
loses her rosen and is replaced by
another girl when she is alone backstage
a group of men forcefully drag her to
their car goo senses that his daughter
is not among the performers and gives
her a call she picks up but goo only
hears the sound of her screams he runs
to the parking lot but his second's too
late to catch the vehicle after that he
quickly makes a call to the police a few
hours later goo is told that sia's
deformed dead body has been found near a
river she was attacked with acid and
left to die to identify the body goo
touches her hand and discovers that it
is not his daughter sia has been playing
violin for over 10 years and her fingers
have thick calluses on them this body
doesn't have anything of such sort which
proves that she is still alive goo
explains everything to the police
officer but the man refuses to believe
him he says the id card found in her
pocket is enough evidence and no further
actions will be taken in a fit of rage
goo attacks the officer and the incident
is broadcasted live on tv meanwhile in
prison xena sees the news and is
delighted to see goo suffering after
discovering that he's in manula she
signs the consent form to be transferred
to a prison there in the next scene she
is masked chained and surrounded by many
guards while on the way to the new
prison suddenly the vehicle stops and
xena comes out with a gun in her hand
having killed everyone inside in less
than a minute she also ambushes all the
guards following them and eventually
escapes when kang finds out about the
escape he kills a guard in anger he
orders more men to find her as soon as
possible assuming that his father will
only attain peace when she dies
somewhere else gu is in handcuffs being
told that his daughter is definitely
dead he realizes that the police are not
going to help him and instead send him
back home hence when he gets the chance
he knocks out two of them and tries to
escape what he doesn't know is that xena
had been sitting in the front seat
waiting for him to do just that instead
of killing him instantly she pretends to
be a good police officer who will help
him find his daughter then we finally
get to see sia with many other girls
they have been abducted by none other
than gangster kang he runs a huge
traffic ring kidnapping girls from
around the globe and selling them
through the dark web he takes extra
interest in sia because of her beauty
and raises her price ah what a
compliment simultaneously since xena
knows everything about kang's traffic
ring she tells goo exactly how they can
find his daughter the police won't help
them because they have been bribed to
keep their mouths shut when it comes to
kang's business even though xena wants
to kill sia in the end she is willing to
be on goo's side until then they decide
to use xena as bait and get into the
place where trafficked girls are capped
with her help goo finds the number of a
local dealer who accepts the girl and
sends them to an old woman she is the
mediator in charge of checking if the
girls are good enough for their clients
she approves of xena but senses that goo
is not there with good intentions after
sending xena inside the woman points a
gun at goo but he uses his intuition to
knock her out before she shoots then he
follows xena behind but both of them are
caught right after by now the live
stream on the dark web has started many
clients are watching the girls perform
one after another bidding money for
their lives when it is cia's turn she
plays the violin beautifully kang turns
the live stream off wanting the girl all
for himself but when he tries to touch
her she attacks him kang promises to
teach her a lesson tomorrow and
increases her price by 6 million yuan
somewhere else xena is hung upside down
and goo is bound by a chained caller
kang's partner beth comes to taunt xena
and remind her of her boyfriend's death
when xena in turn makes fun of her she
is drowned until she gets dizzy and then
brought back up goo manages to break his
handcuffs but is easily overpowered by
the gangsters when beth walks out for
some time he manages to turn the fight
around and kill every one of them he
also breaks the water tank and saves
xena's life beth tells kang that she has
caught xena but upon returning to check
up on the prisoners both xena and goo
are ready to attack her she is held
hostage and asked to reveal where sia is
the woman only opens her mouth once a
glass shard is held to her neck she
doesn't know which one is goo's daughter
but all the girls kidnapped within the
last week are with a man named mai who
is also kang's right-hand man suddenly
the police inspector rama arrives at the
scene with his squad before beth is
caught xena pushes her making the glass
shard go deep into her throat and kill
her then the two run away to a house
that xena claims belongs to her in
reality it belongs to one of the police
officers she killed when she escaped
prison goo still doesn't suspect her and
continues cleaning his injuries
somewhere else kang is told about beth's
death so he sends his right-hand man mai
to kill the escapees a while later rama
knocks on the apartment door alongside
mai and his people goo gets a hint of
this channels his inner macaulay culkin
and sets up several traps in the house
when they break in the gas cylinder
blows up killing half of the gangsters
maya attacks goo while zena fights the
rest of the insignificant enemies goo is
about to be killed until he jumps out
the window using the rope he said
earlier he meets mai again in the
hallway and captures him using the same
rope which is now tied to an elevator
upon being tortured mai brings them to
the storage unit where the stolen girls
are kept they set many girls free but
sia is not one of them this means that
she has either already been sold or she
is at kang's place waiting to be sold
the next day at the police station jan
arrives and inquires about progress rama
has made in the case when rama refuses
to share information he goes looking for
his friend on his own meanwhile goo
holds xena at knifepoint and asks her to
reveal who she is it turns out that he
sensed the smell of a rotten corpse in
the apartment that xena claimed was hers
she simply smiles and says the same
words she said when her boyfriend died
goo registers who she is and calls her a
crazy woman before they talk further
yawn arrives and points a gun at xena
she quickly kills mai to be the only
person who knows where sia is if they
kill her at this point they might never
get to cecia which gives her an
advantage xena orders goo to choose
between his friend and his daughter if
he chooses the latter he will have to
kill yon at this instant without
hesitating goo chooses his daughter and
stabs yawn but not deep enough to kill
him after that the partners sit down
inside a car and talk about their pasts
xena reveals that she was sold to a gang
by her father who she killed years later
ever since her birth her only family had
been her late boyfriend which is why she
wants to kill goo in front of his
daughter and turn her into a person just
like her goo acknowledges that it is an
ultimate punishment but he needs her
help to get to his daughter in the first
place after that they go to a local
black market gun seller he was a
middleman who sold xena to the gangsters
hence she kills him before stealing the
entire bus of arms and ammunition one
thing goo doesn't forget to get is the
man's bouncy balls in the following
scene sia is brought outside for the
next dark web live stream kang gives her
the option to either stay with him or be
sold to a stranger but as a reply sia
says that her father is coming to get
her right then the vehicle breaks into
the main entrance and zena starts firing
randomly at everyone since she is
protected by the vehicle none of the
bullets fired at them get her amidst the
chaos goo is able to throw a bouncy ball
at sia to tell her he is here she safely
keeps the ball with her waiting for him
to take her home the guards are
foolishly sent outside to fight the two
when they have already entered the house
they turn the lights off and proceed to
kill all the guards one after another
eventually kang is left with only his
lawyer and sia the lawyer also abandons
him saying that he is better off dead as
a last resort kang attaches a time bomb
to sia but before anything else he is
shot and killed by xena after that she
hangs sia upside down with a chain if
goo knows where she is he can pick her
up hence she throws the bouncy ball at
him goo catches the ball and locates her
successfully he also shoots xena dead
right before catching his daughter
however the storm hasn't passed yet as
the bomb is still attached to her right
then jan arrives revealing that his
wound wasn't fatal he helps goo by
giving him tools to defuse the explosive
the plan works and all the good people
are saved in the end in the last scene
jan and sia come to see goo in prison
they indulge in happy conversations
about life and dating not at all
traumatized by the events of the film
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching